les six jeunes avaient cherché la
physique des pollens temps
le monde
je n'ai pas le temps
et si parce que formé par l'interaction
entre la lumière et la matière
à la lumière était resté
suffisamment fortement avec la matière
on ne peut que distinguer le flottant la
partie du bien
de la matière on parlera alors de
nouvelles parce qu'elle s'appelle paul
habitants
faute de vent
bon nombre de domaine
les avantages que ce n'est pas le temps
d une statuette c'est parce qu'il aime
qui possède à la fois les avantages de
la lumière et ceux de la matière
les avantages provenant de la partie il
ya
sans qui peuvent être facilement
détectées il fascine à manipuler par
exemple de lazard et de caméras les
arabes à ce qu'il ya de la matière
sans que les polars étant intéresse
très efficacement un truc quant à
manfred anti ne peut jamais entrés en
collision ça nous permet d'exister dans
un cadre technologique par exemple pour
fabriquer mais l'asa plus efficace des
transports plus efficaces
mais également dans un autre contexte
on a un mental pour équidés des
phénomènes nouveaux plus exotique
comme par exemple les coûts humains de
polaris temps
cinq viscosité deux flûtes de paulette
temps dans une soute
vie